This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In the 1939 movie, The Wizard of Oz, one of the central characters is the cowardly line. He cuts a figure that is recognizable to us all. He longs to be brave, but when his courage is tested, he shrinks in fear. Look at that. Look at that. I want to go home. The cowardly lion eventually discovers his true nature. When he is given a medal to honor his courage,
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在1939年的电影《绿野仙踪》中，核心角色之一是胆小狮。他给人的印象是我们所有人都熟悉的。他渴望变得勇敢，但当他的勇气受到考验时，他却因恐惧而退缩。看那个。看那个。我想回家。胆小狮最终发现了自己的本性。当他被授予一枚奖章以表彰他的勇气时，
it helps him see that he is, in fact, a lion, that he was brave all along. The moral of the story is clear. The lion always had the capacity to be brave. He just didn't know it. The Wizard of Oz is a work of fiction, but every day we see the cowardly lion's dilemma entails from real life. situations where people are called upon to be brave.
这让他明白，他其实是一头狮子，他一直都很勇敢。故事的寓意很明确。狮子一直都有勇敢的能力。他只是不知道而已。《绿野仙踪》是一部虚构作品，但我们每天都能在现实生活中看到胆小狮的困境。人们被要求勇敢的时刻。
Sometimes they rise to the occasion, but many fail to do so, often with disastrous consequences. Fear, of course, is not always a bad thing. Evolutionary biologists find that circuits in the brain that govern the fear response are ancient, but fear can keep us from living our best lives, reaching for our dreams, and upholding our values. This week on Hidden Brain
有时他们能挺身而出，但许多人却做不到，往往会带来灾难性的后果。当然，恐惧并不总是一件坏事。进化生物学家发现，大脑中控制恐惧反应的回路是古老的，但恐惧会阻碍我们过上最好的生活，追求梦想，坚持我们的价值观。本周在《Hidden Brain》
and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, how to discover our inner lion. into a burning building or standing up to an armed enemy. Other times it involves speaking up when everyone else stays silent or stepping forward when your instinct is to shrink back. Today, we look at those defining moments when life calls on us to be brave when the choice is between cowardice and courage. Ranjay Gullati is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School.
以及《Hidden Brain Plus》的配套剧集中，我们将探讨如何发现我们内心的狮子。冲进燃烧的建筑物或对抗武装敌人。有时，它涉及在其他人保持沉默时大声疾呼，或者在你的本能是退缩时挺身而出。今天，我们来看看那些当生活要求我们勇敢时，在懦弱与勇气之间做出选择的关键时刻。兰杰·古拉蒂是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。
He studies how people behave under conditions of great risk. He has thought a lot about the next. nature of courage. Ranjay, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's a pleasure to be here today. Ranjay, you've looked into the story of a high school language teacher in China. On the afternoon of May 12, 2008, he was in his classroom conducting a lesson. Tell me who he was and what happened next?
他研究人们在巨大风险条件下的行为。他深入思考过勇气的本质。兰杰，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴今天能来到这里。兰杰，你研究过中国一位高中语文老师的故事。2008年5月12日下午，他正在教室里上课。告诉我他是谁，接下来发生了什么？
Fanme Zong was a teacher and he was in the middle of his class talking about an esoteric 18th century literary Chinese scholar when the building started to shake. You know, it got a little uncomfortable, but then the tremor turned into a full-blown earthquake where now everything was shaking. And van Meizong didn't hesitate. He ran. He opened the door and he ran out of the building. He was the first one out of the building, actually. And he got to the main ground and in fact the boundary wall around the ground starts to collapse also wow and the students eventually also come out and he asked his students where were you why didn't you come out and they asked him where were you we got so scared we actually hid under the table and we were hiding
范美忠是一位老师，他当时正在课堂上讲解一位深奥的18世纪中国文学学者，这时建筑物开始摇晃。你知道，这让人有点不安，但随后震动变成了全面的地震，现在一切都在摇晃。范美忠没有犹豫。他跑了。他打开门，跑出了大楼。事实上，他是第一个跑出大楼的人。他到达了主操场，事实上，操场周围的围墙也开始倒塌。哇，学生们最终也出来了，他问他的学生，你们在哪里？为什么没有出来？他们问他，你在哪里？我们太害怕了，实际上躲在桌子底下，我们躲在
under our desks waiting for direction on what to do their question was you're our teacher you should have been there to help us get out of there rather than run out of there first and run out of there first. And Fanbizond had no remorse whatsoever and he said
课桌下等待指示该怎么做。他们的问题是，你是我们的老师，你应该在那里帮助我们逃生，而不是自己先跑出来。范美忠对此毫无悔意，他说
look when it comes to my own physical safety I am a coward and so I needed to save myself first and that was how he completely rationalized his response. So eventually the earthquake resulted in nearly 90,000 people reported or presumed dead. Many children died across the region when school buildings crumbled on top of them.
看，当涉及到我自己的身体安全时，我是一个懦夫，所以我需要先救自己，这就是他完全合理化自己反应的方式。最终，地震导致近9万人被报告或推定死亡。该地区许多儿童在校舍倒塌在他们身上时丧生。
As news reports got out about this teacher's behavior, what was the public reaction, Ranjay? The public's reaction was one of outrage. At one point, he was considered the most hated man in China. They had derogatory nicknames for him, like a running fan. And so he then comes out and speaks and tries to defend and justify his own action. And this has an even bigger backlash on him. As a society, we really can't stand cowards.
当关于这位老师行为的新闻报道传出时，公众的反应是什么，兰杰？公众的反应是愤怒。一度，他被认为是全中国最令人憎恨的人。他们给他起了贬义的绰号，比如“范跑跑”。于是他出来说话，试图为自己的行为辩护和开脱。这反而对他造成了更大的反弹。作为一个社会，我们真的无法容忍懦夫。
cowardice is one of the most derogatory terms you can use to label somebody and that was the label pinned on fan he lost his job and it didn't end for several months after you tell another story about a life-threatening emergency this one occurred in 23 on the subway in New York City, a man named Adam Klotz was riding the train when he saw something happening in the subway car. What did he observe and what did he do, Ranj? So Adam Klotz is a meteorologist. He's on his way to work and he sees some young kids harassing an older gentleman. And, you know, as a good Samaritan and a good citizen, he chooses
懦弱是你可以用来给某人贴上的最贬义的标签之一，这就是贴在范身上的标签。他丢了工作，而且在接下来的几个月里都没有结束。你讲了另一个关于危及生命的紧急情况的故事，这次发生在23年的纽约地铁上，一个名叫亚当·克洛茨的人在乘火车时看到地铁车厢里发生了什么事。他观察到了什么，又做了什么，兰杰？所以亚当·克洛茨是一位气象学家。他在上班路上，看到几个年轻人正在骚扰一位年长的绅士。而且，你知道，作为一个好撒玛利亚人和好公民，他选择
to intervene. Nobody else is doing anything. And he just asked them to stop doing what they were doing. And that then leads them to redirect attention to him. He then tries to avoid confrontation by going to another car. They follow him. And at some point they start to beat him up rather viciously. And nobody else comes to his defense. And that to him was the shocker that nobody else stood up for him
进行干预。没有其他人做任何事。他只是要求他们停止他们的行为。这导致他们将注意力转向了他。他试图通过去另一节车厢来避免冲突。他们跟着他。在某个时刻，他们开始非常恶毒地殴打他。没有其他人站出来保护他。对他来说，最令人震惊的是没有人像他保护那位年长绅士那样站出来支持他。
the way he had for the older gentleman. So here we see examples of both courage and cowardice in a single subway car. Ranjay, I understand that you yourself once saw this juxtaposition of courage and cowardice in your own life. You were a teenager living in India with your mother. She had started a successful business. Set the scene for me and tell me what happened. So my mother was a successful fashion designer.
所以在这里，我们在同一节地铁车厢里看到了勇气和懦弱的例子。兰杰，我了解到你自己也曾在生活中看到过这种勇气与懦弱的并置。你十几岁时和母亲住在印度。她创办了一家成功的企业。为我设定场景，告诉我发生了什么。所以我的母亲是一位成功的时装设计师。
She had a business and she bought herself a piece of farmland outside New Delhi where she was going to have a farmhouse for the weekend getaway. This land turned out to become very valuable. A developer was chasing her to buy it. She said, I don't want it. I don't want to sell. I don't want the money. I want to keep my land.
她有一家公司，她在新德里郊外为自己买了一块农田，打算在那里建一个周末度假的农舍。这块地后来变得非常有价值。一位开发商一直在追着她买。她说，我不想要。我不想卖。我不想要钱。我想保留我的土地。
So one day I'm home on a weekend and this gentleman comes to the gate and he asked to see my mom and he's from the developer. I said, no, she's not going to meet you. and he said, listen, tell her, this is the last time we'll ever bother her. She says, okay, fine, send him in. Just a regular gentleman wearing a blazer comes in, sits down, across from my mother, where she's sitting on her sofa. And he puts in front of on the table a blank check, signed.
所以有一天周末我在家，这位绅士来到门口，要求见我妈妈，他是开发商派来的。我说，不，她不会见你的。他说，听着，告诉她，这是我们最后一次打扰她。她说，好吧，让他进来。一个穿着西装外套的普通绅士走进来，坐在我母亲对面，她坐在沙发上。他在桌子上放了一张签了名的空白支票。
And a piece of paper and says, ma'am, you enter the amount. Whatever you want. We just want to buy this from you. She says, no, I really don't want to sell. I'm sorry, here's your check back. There's no amount for which I want to sell this land. gets my belligerent she pushes back and says
还有一张纸，说，女士，你自己填金额。无论你想要多少。我们只是想从你这里买下它。她说，不，我真的不想卖。对不起，把你的支票拿回去。无论多少钱，我都不想卖这块地。他变得好战，她反击说
no I'm not selling he finally says ma'am I can't leave without your signature today I have to get your signature so she says well I'm sorry you're not going to at this point he pulls his blazer back and he reveals he has a gun tucked in his waist
不，我不卖。他最后说，女士，今天没有你的签名我不能离开。我必须得到你的签名。所以她说，好吧，对不起，你得不到。就在这时，他拉开西装外套，露出腰间藏着一把枪。
I'm standing at the door watching this whole thing unfold I see the gun too in my mind I'm doing my cost benefit you know I'm looking at the timing should I wait should I wait Should I let him reach for the gun? Maybe it's a bluff.
我站在门口看着这一切发生，我也看到了枪。在我的脑海里，我正在做成本效益分析，你知道，我正在观察时机，我应该等吗？我应该等吗？我应该让他去拿枪吗？也许这是虚张声势。
Should I go call the guard at the gate? I'm working this out in my head. My mother doesn't hesitate at all. She gets her from our sofa, walks across the table, and slaps him right across the face. He doesn't even see it coming. And then she says, how dare you? How dare you come into my house
我应该去叫门口的警卫吗？我在脑子里盘算着。我母亲一点也没有犹豫。她从沙发上站起来，走到桌子对面，直接扇了他一巴掌。他甚至没看到这一巴掌。然后她说，你怎么敢？你怎么敢闯进我的房子
and try to bully me and try to tell me to give you my land and you're going to threaten me with a gun? Get out of here. He doesn't see it coming. He scampers away forgetting his checkbook. I have to run after him to give him his checkbook. And I then asked my mom, I said, Mom, didn't you see he had a gun?
试图欺负我，试图告诉我把土地给你，还要用枪威胁我？滚出去。他没料到会这样。他落荒而逃，忘了他的支票簿。我不得不追上去把支票簿还给他。然后我问我妈，我说，妈，你没看到他有枪吗？
She says, yes. I said, what are you scared? She said, yes. So what? When you thought about your own behavior in that moment, Ranjay, I mean, it's perfectly understandable why you would freeze in that moment. But when you reflected back on yourself, did you see some deeper character trait that prompted you not to act in that moment?
她说，看到了。我说，那你怕吗？她说，怕。那又怎样？当你反思那一刻自己的行为时，兰杰，我的意思是，在那一刻你会僵住是完全可以理解的。但当你回顾自己时，你是否看到了某种促使你在那一刻没有采取行动的更深层的性格特征？
I think, you know, maybe there was something in myself, when I was a naturally hesitant. I would always deliberate before action. And sometimes my deliberations would take longer than normal. And whereas my mother was a very, you know, being a self-made businesswoman, she was a very confident person. And I think in her mind, she had a sense of herself as somebody who had a can-do mindset like many entrepreneurs do.
我想，你知道，也许我内心深处有一些东西，我天生就比较犹豫。我总是会在行动前深思熟虑。有时我的深思熟虑比正常情况要长。而我母亲，作为一个白手起家的女商人，她是一个非常自信的人。我认为在她心中，她把自己看作是一个像许多企业家一样拥有“能行”心态的人。
and as a woman growing up in that time in India where it was a very paternalistic system, she was not easy to be pushed around and she was often being pushed around by a very male-dominated society and system. So my own hesitation, I think, was a thoughtful cost-benefit, let's do the risk-adjusted returns, if I may say, so, you know, I'm doing my risk analysis,
作为一个在那个时代的印度长大的女性，在一个非常父权制的体系中，她不容易被摆布，她经常被一个非常男性主导的社会和体系所摆布。所以我想我自己的犹豫是一种深思熟虑的成本效益分析，如果我可以这样说的话，你知道，我正在做我的风险分析，
scenario planning, working out of the scenarios, in my head, which I thought was okay. I mean, that's what I'm supposed to do. But it was a learning moment. It was a, it was a learning moment from me. In the aftermath of this, did you feel like a coward? Absolutely. I did. You know, again, as, even though I was only 14 years, old, you know, as her son, I felt like it was my duty and responsibility to be the one to have protected her versus her having to do it for herself. But it also made me realize very quickly that fear can paralyze you and that you have to make a choice sometimes. And she didn't give
场景规划，在脑子里推演各种场景，我认为这没问题。我的意思是，这就是我应该做的。但这对我来说是一个学习的时刻。这是一个学习的时刻。事后，你觉得自己是个懦夫吗？绝对是。我确实觉得。你知道，再次强调，尽管我当时只有14岁，你知道，作为她的儿子，我觉得保护她是我的职责和责任，而不是让她自己去保护自己。但这也让我很快意识到，恐惧会让你瘫痪，有时你必须做出选择。她没有在事后
me a long lecture afterwards. She just said, just because you're scared doesn't mean you do nothing. And that line kind of has always stayed with me. Just because you're scared doesn't mean you do nothing. Life frequently presents us with moments that require a fateful choice. Will we hang back in a state of fear and cowardice? Or will we plunge ahead into brave and courageous action? When we come back, the attitude. and practices that separate the timid from the bold.
给我长篇大论。她只是说，仅仅因为你害怕并不意味着你什么都不做。那句话一直伴随着我。仅仅因为你害怕并不意味着你什么都不做。生活经常给我们呈现出需要做出重大选择的时刻。我们是会停留在恐惧和懦弱的状态中吗？还是会勇往直前，采取勇敢的行动？当我们回来时，我们将探讨区分胆小者与勇敢者的态度和实践。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ranjee Gulati is a behavior. behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He has seen examples of courage and cowardice in his own life and in stories drawn from the news. When he sees stories of people acting courageously,
你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。兰杰·古拉蒂是一位哈佛商学院的行为科学家。他在自己的生活中以及从新闻中汲取的故事里看到过勇气和懦弱的例子。当他看到人们勇敢行事的故事时，
he asks himself, what allowed these people to live up to their values, to stand up for what's right? Ranjay, a few years ago, a question started to nag at you, and you decided to investigate it scientifically. What was this question? The question really was, how do people operate in the face of uncertainty? Risk is where you have tools to assess, quantify, even mitigate it.
他问自己，是什么让这些人能够坚持自己的价值观，为正确的事情挺身而出？兰杰，几年前，一个问题开始困扰你，你决定科学地调查它。这个问题是什么？这个问题实际上是，人们如何在不确定性面前运作？风险是你拥有评估、量化甚至减轻它的工具的地方。
Uncertainty is like a thick fog, no clear odds, no fool-truth strategies. It turns out that most of us are able to deal with risk, tackle risk. We make money off of risk in the entire field of finance. Uncertainty actually activates the amygdala and it triggers what is considered a survival emotion, fear. It moves quickly and it paralyzes us. So people say fight or flight. It's actually fight, flight or freeze. And fight is the rarest of all responses. It's mostly flight or freeze. I have no scientific basis for this, but I would like to hypothesize that most of us are descendants of cowards. Our ancestors, the ones who made it, ran for cover. The ones who ran for
不确定性就像浓雾，没有明确的几率，没有万无一失的策略。事实证明，我们大多数人能够处理风险，应对风险。我们在整个金融领域通过风险赚钱。不确定性实际上激活了杏仁核，并触发了被认为是生存情绪的恐惧。它移动迅速，使我们瘫痪。所以人们说战斗或逃跑。实际上是战斗、逃跑或僵住。而战斗是所有反应中最罕见的。主要是逃跑或僵住。我对此没有科学依据，但我愿意假设我们大多数人都是懦夫的后代。我们的祖先，那些活下来的人，都跑去寻找掩护了。那些跑去
Then after danger didn't quite make it. Now, at the same time, humankind has only progressed by virtue of those feud, the daring feud, the right brothers risking their lives to say, I'm going to give it to try, Madam Curie, others who personally took risk also for themselves, whether it was Mahatma Gandhi, Martin Luther King, Nelson Mandela, all these people put themselves at risk. we are all the beneficiaries of those bold actions. Can you talk about the idea that from ancient times, people have puzzled over why some of us are braver than others, and one school of thought has held that bravery is just something that is innate in some people. Some people just happen to be brave. this is a real question
然后躲避危险的人并没有完全活下来。现在，与此同时，人类的进步完全归功于那些少数人，那些大胆的少数人，莱特兄弟冒着生命危险说，我要试一试，居里夫人，以及其他亲自承担风险的人，无论是圣雄甘地、马丁·路德·金、纳尔逊·曼德拉，所有这些人将自己置于风险之中。我们都是这些大胆行动的受益者。你能谈谈从古至今人们一直困惑为什么有些人比其他人更勇敢，而一个学派认为勇敢只是某些人与生俱来的东西吗？有些人碰巧就是勇敢的。这是一个真正的问题
because as I looked at the biographies of some of these people, you know, you read Mahatma Gandhi, he was not always a courageous person. Very early in his life, he was trying to be a barrister. He was living in England. He wanted to be more English than the English themselves.
因为当我研究其中一些人的传记时，你知道，你读圣雄甘地的故事，他并不总是勇敢的人。在他生命的早期，他试图成为一名大律师。他住在英国。他想变得比英国人更像英国人。
Right? And then he had a moment of realization that changed things for him. He was horrible public speaker. He was absolutely frightened of speaking in public. And here you have somebody who then speaks to millions of people. So you start to see that some of these people actually cultivate courage.
对吧？然后他有了一个改变他一切的顿悟时刻。他是一个糟糕的公众演说家。他非常害怕在公共场合发言。而在这里，你有一个后来对数百万人发表演讲的人。所以你开始看到，这些人中的一些人实际上是培养了勇气。
And you discover that courage is a choice. It's a choice you make. And it's a choice you make in the face of fear. It forces you to become acquainted with the discomfort we feel when we are scared. Let's examine some of the things that courageous people do. You say that they construct the right kind of narrative What are these narratives and why are they important, Renji? So, Max Weber, a famous sociologist in the last century,
你发现勇气是一种选择。这是一种你做出的选择。而且这是你在面对恐惧时做出的选择。它迫使你熟悉当我们害怕时感到的不适。让我们检查一下勇敢的人所做的一些事情。你说他们构建了正确类型的叙事。这些叙事是什么，为什么它们很重要，兰杰？所以，马克斯·韦伯，上个世纪一位著名的社会学家，
talked about how human behavior can either be rational, which is looking at all options and trying to evaluate those choices, or interpretive. Interpretive is where you're looking at everything through a lens of meaning, understanding. What does it mean for me? and what is the meaning of the situation. So this narrative is how we construct a story about the situation.
谈到了人类行为要么是理性的，即查看所有选项并试图评估这些选择，要么是解释性的。解释性是指你通过意义和理解的镜头来看待一切。这对意味着什么？这种情况的意义是什么。所以这种叙事是我们如何构建关于这种情况的故事。
What's going on here? Is it personally meaningful to me? And a story we construct of ourselves in that situation. And most times this interpretive calculus takes us to freeze or flight. But sometimes we feel compelled. I have to do something. this situation is the moment where if I don't do it, I can't live with myself. One of the stories that you say can support our efforts to be courageous is what you call a moral quest.
这里发生了什么？它对我个人有意义吗？以及我们在那种情况下构建的关于我们自己的故事。大多数时候，这种解释性的计算会让我们僵住或逃跑。但有时我们感到被迫。我必须做点什么。这种情况是如果我不做，我就无法面对自己的时刻。你说可以支持我们努力变得勇敢的故事之一是你所说的道德追求。
Talk about this idea. You've mentioned Mahatma Gandhi, you've mentioned Nelson Mandela, Martin Luther King Jr. All of them, it would seem, were not just on a political journey, but on a moral journey of some kind. I think most of us inside ourselves want to be great at something. I want to be somebody.
谈谈这个想法。你提到了圣雄甘地，你提到了纳尔逊·曼德拉，马丁·路德·金。他们所有人，似乎不仅是在进行政治旅程，而且是在进行某种道德旅程。我认为我们大多数人内心深处都想在某方面变得伟大。我想成为某个人。
I want to be known for something. And when you encounter something that you really buy into as a morally potent idea, it elevates our thought. We feel a sense of responsibility. I need to do something. thing. In a previous project I did, I wrote a book called Deep Purpose in which I looked at even
我想因为某事而闻名。当你遇到你真正认同为具有道德力量的想法时，它会提升我们的思想。我们感到一种责任感。我需要做点什么。在我之前做的一个项目中，我写了一本书叫《深度目标》，其中我研究了甚至
startups. They start not only with an idea. They usually start with an ideal. We want to change the way this thing gets done. We're going to transform the way these customers have to do this. We're going to completely redo the way this is done. And that energizes people in these small companies. In fact, when the companies get big, they lose it. And then they're like, oh, my God, we lost our soul. I remember speaking many years ago with Scott Atron. He studies extremist groups and violent movements and so forth. But one of the things he looks at is this idea that, you know, all of us are motivated, of course, by, you know, costs and benefits. We are making cost-benefit calculations as we go through life. But he talks about the set of beliefs that we can
初创公司。它们不仅以一个想法开始。它们通常以一个理想开始。我们想改变这种事情的完成方式。我们将改变这些客户必须这样做的方式。我们将彻底重做这种事情的完成方式。这激励了这些小公司的人。事实上，当公司变大时，他们就失去了它。然后他们就像，哦，天哪，我们失去了灵魂。我记得多年前与斯科特·阿特兰交谈过。他研究极端组织和暴力运动等等。但他观察的事情之一是这个想法，你知道，我们所有人当然都受到成本和收益的激励。我们在生活中不断进行成本效益计算。但他谈到了我们可以
have, which he called sacred values. And sacred values are things that in some ways are not amenable to cost-benefit calculations. If someone were to say, you know, how much money would you be willing to accept in exchange for your child's life? You would say no amount of money is going to be worth it because my child's life is not connected to the realm of transaction of buying and selling, that there's no amount that you could give me that would allow me to betray my country or to betray my family. In some ways, I think that's what you're talking about when you talk about having a moral quest. In some ways, it moves the conversation from a cost-benefit calculation to something that in some ways is beyond it. Absolutely. But I don't want to make the distinction
拥有的那套信念，他称之为神圣价值观。神圣价值观在某种程度上是不受成本效益计算影响的。如果有人问，你愿意接受多少钱来换取你孩子的生命？你会说多少钱都不值得，因为我孩子的生命与买卖的交易领域无关，没有任何金额可以让你让我背叛我的国家或背叛我的家人。在某种程度上，我认为这就是你谈论拥有道德追求时所指的。在某种程度上，它将对话从成本效益计算转移到了某种在某种程度上超越它的东西上。绝对是。但我不想把这种区别
so clean. I think we're doing cost-benefit while we are also doing this other factor that is compelling us to take action. So it's usually the intersection of the two, right? I don't know my mother's no longer here, but I'm not sure if the guy had already pointed the gun and had his finger on the trigger that she would have tried to work around him, right? I would imagine that in her mind, she must have decided that if I had a moment, it's now or never. And as she explained later, she says, he was determined to get my signature. He had said clearly, his intention was, I'm not leaving here without your signature. So his next move would have been to actually pull that gun out. right he had just shown it to her so in some ways it was a brilliant preemptive move so these ideas
弄得那么干净。我认为我们在进行成本效益分析的同时，也在进行这种促使我们采取行动的其他因素。所以通常是两者的交集，对吧？我不知道我母亲已经不在了，但我不知道如果那个人已经用枪指着她，手指扣在扳机上，她是否会试图绕过他，对吧？我想象在她的脑海里，她一定决定了如果我有机会，就是现在或永远。正如她后来解释的那样，她说，他决心得到我的签名。他已经明确表示，他的意图是，没有你的签名我不会离开这里。所以他的下一步将是真正拔出那把枪。对，他刚刚向她展示了它，所以在某种程度上，这是一个绝妙的先发制人的举动。所以这些想法
kind of intersect where there is a utilitarian thought process and then there is a emotional thought process and that are coming together and hopefully they intersect or sometimes what I found is the emotional trumps utilitarian. You're like, I'm going to do this no matter what. I don't care. That's where it goes to another whole different level. Years ago, Ranjay, you had a student at Harvard Business School who went on to work at Facebook. The rest of the world was introduced.
在某种程度上交叉，有一种功利主义的思维过程，然后有一种情感的思维过程，它们结合在一起，希望它们交叉，或者有时我发现情感胜过功利主义。你会想，无论如何我都要这样做。我不在乎。这就是它上升到另一个完全不同水平的地方。多年前，兰杰，你在哈佛商学院有一位学生后来去了Facebook工作。世界其他地方被介绍
to this former student of yours in October 2021 when she testified before a congressional subcommittee. Here's a bit of what she said. My name is Francis Howgan. I used to work at Facebook. I joined Facebook because I think Facebook has the potential to bring out the best in us. But I'm here today because I believe Facebook's products harm children, stoke division, and weaken our democracy. The company's leadership knows how to make Facebook and Instagram saver, but won't make the necessary changes because they have put their astronomical profits before people. So Runji, it must have taken considerable courage for Francis Hogan to stand up to a behemoth like Facebook. She wasn't just walking away from a job. She was walking
给这位你曾经的学生是在2021年10月，当时她在国会小组委员会作证。这是她所说的一部分。我的名字是弗朗西斯·豪根。我曾经在Facebook工作。我加入Facebook是因为我认为Facebook有潜力激发我们最好的一面。但我今天在这里是因为我相信Facebook的产品伤害了儿童，煽动了分裂，并削弱了我们的民主。公司领导层知道如何让Facebook和Instagram更安全，但不会做出必要的改变，因为他们把天文数字般的利润置于人民之上。所以兰杰，弗朗西斯·豪根站出来对抗像Facebook这样的庞然大物一定需要相当大的勇气。她不仅仅是离开一份工作。她是在离开
away from her career, from coworkers, from friends. You say that she embedded her actions in a moral quest? Absolutely. I think, you know, for her having seen firsthand, one of her own friends getting radicalized by content on Facebook, she had felt it and seen it up front. It was not an abstraction anymore. And I think that brought her to a point where she felt she had to do something, that doing nothing was not an option. We had this notion of the lone hero myth in courage. She didn't do it alone. She pondered it for several months and only when she had a support squad who were really able to nudge her forward was she finally willing to go all the way
她的职业生涯，她的同事，她的朋友。你说她将自己的行动嵌入了一个道德追求中？绝对是。我认为，你知道，对于她来说，亲眼目睹了她的一位朋友被Facebook上的内容激进化，她亲身感受并看到了它。它不再是一个抽象的概念。我认为这把她带到了一个点，她觉得她必须做点什么，什么都不做不是一个选择。我们对勇气有这种孤独英雄的神话。她不是一个人做的。她思考了几个月，只有当她有一个真正能够推动她前进的支持团队时，她才最终愿意一路走到底。
so courage is not a solo sport it takes a village and so you have to curate the right kind of support she got emotional support from her parents and friends she got informational or knowledge support from a law firm that specialized in helping whistleblowers
所以勇气不是一项单人运动，它需要一个村庄，所以你必须策划正确类型的支持。她从父母和朋友那里得到了情感支持，她从一家专门帮助举报人的律师事务所那里得到了信息或知识支持，
she got resource support from news media that was going to cover her story and she got feedback support from a friend of hers who was actually an ordained priest with whom she would have candid conversations would tell her what she was doing or not doing and whether it felt right or not.
她从将要报道她故事的新闻媒体那里得到了资源支持，她从她的一位朋友那里得到了反馈支持，那个人实际上是一位受戒的牧师，她会与他进行坦诚的对话，他会告诉她她在做什么或没做什么，以及这感觉是否正确。
So, you know, there were this multitude of support that along with her own sense of morality that brought her to a point where she felt she had to do something. And in some ways, I think I'm seeing the same scaffolding in many of the stories that you have told me around Jays. So if you think about Gandhi or King or Mandela, they also in some ways combined, you know, a deep moral fervor with real strategy and real tactical, you know, sophistication. And Francis Hauken did the same thing.
所以，你知道，有这种多方面的支持，加上她自己的道德感，把她带到了一个点，她觉得她必须做点什么。在某种程度上，我认为我在你告诉我的许多故事中看到了同样的脚手架，兰杰。所以如果你想到甘地、金或曼德拉，他们也在某种程度上结合了深厚的道德热情与真正的战略和真正的战术复杂性。弗朗西斯·豪根也做了同样的事情。
I mean, she had a moral fervor. She believed what she was doing was right. But as you say, she in some ways got her legs under her before she decided to make her move. Absolutely. And the moral fervor doesn't always involve some higher order purpose. it can. In startups, you know, you can see them saying, I want to transform the way this market works. I'm going to change the way this gets done. And so that fervor can take the form of transforming society, transforming a market, transforming others' lives. In some way, and I think
我的意思是，她有道德热情。她相信她所做的是正确的。但正如你所说，她在决定采取行动之前，在某种程度上站稳了脚跟。绝对是。而且道德热情并不总是涉及某种更高阶的目的。它可以。在初创公司，你知道，你可以看到他们说，我想改变这个市场运作的方式。我要改变这种事情的完成方式。所以这种热情可以采取改变社会、改变市场、改变他人生活的形式。在某种程度上，我认为
what you discover is people in these moments who are drawn to these higher order or purposeful endeavors. Instead of being engaged in the project, they are actually inspired by it. They are energized in a very different way, which is why the behavior you see in small, fast-growth startups of employees is not what you see when those same companies hit 500,000, 2,000 employees. You see a decline and change in people's motivation and how they show up. So cultivating courage might start with examining the stories we tell ourselves about our capacities, but we also need to gather information about what's out there, the scary situation that requires our bravery. You talk about the idea of sense-making.
你发现的是，在这些时刻被这些更高阶或有目的的努力所吸引的人。他们不是在参与项目，而是被它所激励。他们以一种非常不同的方式被注入活力，这就是为什么你在小型、快速增长的初创公司员工身上看到的行为，与当这些公司达到500、1000、2000名员工时所看到的不一样。你会看到人们的动机和他们的表现方式出现下降和变化。所以培养勇气可能始于审视我们对自己能力的叙事，但我们也需要收集关于外面有什么的信息，即需要我们勇敢的令人恐惧的情况。你谈到了意义构建的想法。
What is sense-making here in this context, Ranji? So what I discovered was once you've got the kind of the moral fervor and the identity and meaning to move you into wanting, to do something, people resource themselves in a variety of way. They have a set of a toolkit and tactics they absorb. One of the first ones I discovered was sense making. Sense making is a classic term used by a very famous organizational theaters from Michigan named Carl Weik. And Carl Weik looked at firefighters.
在这种背景下，意义构建是什么，兰杰？所以我发现，一旦你有了那种道德热情、身份和意义来推动你想要做点什么，人们就会以各种方式为自己提供资源。他们有一套工具包和策略。我发现的第一个是意义构建。意义构建是一个非常著名的组织理论家，来自密歇根的卡尔·韦克使用的经典术语。卡尔·韦克观察了消防员。
When a firefighter goes into a building, they don't know. There's a tremendous amount of uncertainty. How fast is the fire happening? How combustible is it? Are there other kind of combustible liquids in the building? Are there people in the building who need to be saved? How much time do I have before I need to make a hasty exit? All this is going on.
当消防员进入建筑物时，他们不知道。存在巨大的不确定性。火势蔓延有多快？它有多易燃？建筑物里还有其他种类的可燃液体吗？建筑物里有人需要被救吗？在需要匆忙撤离之前我还有多少时间？所有这些都在进行中。
Now, if you're going to do your risk-adjusting your calculation over here, you're never going to go into the building. They don't have that option. So they go into the building with an initial hypothesis. They've seen the building, the structure. They know how long the fire has been going on. They have a guess as to point. of origin, entry, looking around cues, what's here, what's there, updating your theory, taking
现在，如果你在这里做你的风险调整计算，你永远不会进入建筑物。他们没有那个选择。所以他们带着一个初步假设进入建筑物。他们看到了建筑物，结构。他们知道火已经烧了多久。他们对起源点、入口、观察周围线索、这里有什么、那里有什么有一个猜测，更新你的理论，采取
some more steps. Should I be going upstairs to look for people, should I go into the basement, should I look for point of origin? What should I be doing next? So it's a story of kind of tippy-toeing your way into the fog, what is called acting your way into knowing. Rather than knowing before acting, sometimes you have to act your way into knowing. You say that a masterful example of acting your way into knowing took place in the wake of the major tsunami that hit Japan in 2011. Tell me that story. What happened there that in some ways exemplifies this idea? So everybody knows about the Fukushima Daiichi plant, which had a melt-up.
更多步骤。我应该上楼找人吗，我应该去地下室吗，我应该寻找起源点吗？我接下来应该做什么？所以这是一个在雾中踮着脚尖走的故事，即所谓的“在行动中获得认知”。与其在行动前知道，有时你必须在行动中获得认知。你说一个在行动中获得认知的杰出例子发生在2011年袭击日本的大海啸之后。讲讲那个故事。那里发生了什么，在某种程度上体现了这个想法？所以每个人都知道福岛第一核电站，它发生了熔毁。
Just eight miles away was another plant complex called the Da'ini plant. This too was damaged equally badly. Both of them had a boundary wall of 20 feet high, and the tsunami had crossed 55 feet of water, which had submerged the nuclear reactors, the cooling systems, and everything else. And all these people, the 300-odd employees, had raced into the emergency response center where they were trying to understand what's going on. A power plant like that works off of gauges, sensors and gauges, all blanked. And in there is the plant manager, Masuda.
仅仅八英里外是另一个名为第二核电站的工厂综合体。这也受到了同样严重的破坏。它们都有一个20英尺高的边界墙，而海啸跨越了55英尺的水，淹没了核反应堆、冷却系统和其他一切。所有这些人，那300多名员工，都冲进了应急响应中心，试图了解发生了什么。像那样的发电厂依靠仪表、传感器和仪表，全部变黑了。工厂经理增田就在那里。
Mr. Masuda says, what are we going to do? Headquarters says, we don't know. They don't know. This is okay. He got five volunteers to go outside. and do a wrecky tour to find out how bad are things. So they go out and they find out, well, the power supply to the cooling system is gone. There's no other immediate source of power we can get.
增田先生说，我们该怎么办？总部说，我们不知道。他们不知道。这没关系。他找了五名志愿者去外面。进行侦察，找出情况有多糟糕。所以他们出去发现，冷却系统的电源没了。我们无法获得任何其他直接的电力来源。
So we need to get power back somehow into our systems or else the meltdown is guaranteed. Back. Taking stock. Another group, let's send you out to different sources of power to see, is there any place we can find power? let's send people out to find out about access to cables power cables we'll need cables to create a little extension cord if I may say so now you're trying to grapple with the situation then you start you get the cable you find the power source and you then say let's take it to the nearest reactor to where the power source is they start to do that when they discover
所以我们需要以某种方式让电力回到我们的系统中，否则熔毁是肯定的。回来。盘点。另一组，让我们派你们去不同的电源处看看，有没有我们可以找到电力的地方？让我们派人去找出关于电缆、电力电缆的接入，我们需要电缆来制造一根小延长线，如果我可以这样说的话。现在你正在努力应对这种情况，然后你开始，你得到电缆，你找到电源，然后你说让我们把它带到离电源最近的反应堆。他们开始这样做时发现
another reactor has suddenly the temperatures rising much faster they call GE and say all these reactors were the same model, why is this one heating up much faster? They come back and say, you know, actually this was a slightly older model. It has the same numbering on it, but it's a slightly older version. That's why it's probably heating up faster. So they said, okay, forget taking the power to that first reactor. Let's bring it straight to this other one because this one is heating up too fast. So you know,
另一个反应堆的温度突然上升得快得多。他们打电话给通用电气说，所有这些反应堆都是同一个型号，为什么这个加热得快得多？他们回来后说，你知道，实际上这是一个稍微旧一点的型号。它上面有相同的编号，但它是一个稍微旧一点的版本。这就是为什么它可能加热得更快。所以他们说，好吧，忘了把电力带到第一个反应堆。让我们直接把它带到这另一个，因为这个加热得太快了。所以你知道，
you're going in, improvising, adjusting, and learning by doing. And they successfully avoided catastrophe here. You talk about the importance, Ranjay, of trying to convert uncertainty to risk. And you say that one person who pulled this off in 1974, was a man named Philippe Petit. What did he do? He's a tightrope walker, a daredevil, if you may say so.
你进去，即兴发挥，调整，并在实践中学习。他们成功地避免了这里的灾难。你谈到了兰杰，将不确定性转化为风险的重要性。你说1974年有一个人做到了这一点，他是一个名叫菲利普·珀蒂的人。他做了什么？他是一个走钢丝的人，如果你可以这样说的话，是一个敢死队员。
And, you know, at that time, he walked between the World Trade Center buildings. Subsequently, he's done a walk over the Grand Canyon and several other such feats. So in some extensive writing by him, he actually describes it. He says, people describe me as a daredevil. I don't see myself that way.
而且，你知道，当时，他在世界贸易中心大楼之间行走。随后，他在大峡谷上空进行了行走和其他此类壮举。所以在他的一些广泛著作中，他实际上描述了它。他说，人们形容我是敢死队员。我不那样看自己。
I am very, very methodical, very calculating, very careful. So what you are seeing as completely reckless, to my mind, is methodical, thought-out activity. He spent almost 11 years collecting data on wind patterns and other aberrations that can happen over the Grand Canyon before he did that walk. So what you see as kind of reckless behavior is actually. very, very well thought out. In other words, it's very tightly controlled. At one point, Philip says, if I think I'm a hero who is invincible,
我非常、非常讲究方法，非常精于计算，非常小心。所以你所看到的完全鲁莽，在我看来，是讲究方法、深思熟虑的活动。他在做那次行走之前，花了近11年的时间收集关于风向和可能在大峡谷上空发生的其他异常情况的数据。所以你所看到的鲁莽行为实际上是。非常、非常深思熟虑的。换句话说，它是非常严格控制的。在某个时刻，菲利普说，如果我认为自己是一个无敌的英雄，
I will pay for it with my life. So in other words, he understands that if he actually goes outside the realm of what he has tightly prepared for, if he goes off script, if you will, that's exactly when very bad things happen. Yeah. Now, take another example,
我将用我的生命来付出代价。所以换句话说，他明白如果他真的走出了他严格准备的范围，如果他脱离了剧本，如果可以这样说，那正是非常糟糕的事情发生的时候。是的。现在，再举一个例子，
which is of heroic behavior, is Tom Cruz, who does most of his own stunts. In fact, he drove a motorcycle off of a cliff and then parachuted into the valley and he did it six times till he got it right. And when asked, you know, like, Tom, aren't you scared doing this? And he says two things. One is, he says, yes, I'm afraid,
英雄行为的例子是汤姆·克鲁斯，他自己完成了大部分特技。事实上，他骑摩托车冲下悬崖，然后跳伞进入山谷，他做了六次直到做对为止。当被问到，你知道，像，汤姆，做这个你不怕吗？他说两件事。第一是，他说，是的，我害怕，
but you know, I'm okay and comfortable with being afraid. That's the first thing. So he's tamed and managed his own fear. But at the same time, you should see the entire team that is supporting this effort, right? How they've trained up for this, how they've simulated and planned for this. This is not just Tom finding a random cliff and saying, let's just race off the cliff. So the massive amounts of preparation that have gone in, probably much more than if they'd used a backup stunt artist. So that's where people are taking what looks like an uncertain story.
但你知道，我没问题，并且对感到害怕感到舒适。这是第一件事。所以他驯服并管理了自己的恐惧。但与此同时，你应该看到支持这项努力的整个团队，对吧？他们是如何为此训练的，他们是如何为此模拟和计划的。这不仅仅是汤姆找到一个随机的悬崖说，让我们冲下悬崖。所以投入了大量的准备工作，可能比他们使用替身特技演员要多得多。所以这就是人们将看起来像不确定故事的东西，
turning it into risk and then learning to manage that risk. In order to become brave, we need to tell inspiring stories about ourselves and our journeys. We also need to learn about the nature of the frightening or daunting challenges we face and to deliberately test our abilities
转化为风险，然后学习管理该风险的地方。为了变得勇敢，我们需要讲述关于我们自己和我们旅程的鼓舞人心的故事。我们还需要了解我们面临的令人恐惧或艰巨挑战的本质，并刻意测试我们的能力
to deal with them. When we come back, the role of the psychological factor known as self-efficacy. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had times in your life when you found yourself unable to do the brave thing, when you shrank back from a challenge and fail to live up to your values?
来应对它们。当我们回来时，我们将探讨被称为自我效能感的心理因素的作用。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你的生活中是否有过这样的时刻，当你发现自己无法做勇敢的事情，当你从挑战中退缩并未能坚持你的价值观时？
Or can you think of a moment when you were frightened but somehow managed to be brave. If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode about the science of bravery, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, frightened. Again, that's feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. At a commencement addressed some years ago, the writer
或者你能想到一个你很害怕但以某种方式设法变得勇敢的时刻吗？如果你有一个愿意与《Hidden Brain》听众分享的个人故事，或者关于这一集关于勇敢科学的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间并录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行，frightened。再说一遍，那是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。在几年前的毕业典礼演讲中，作家
and civil rights activist Maya Angelou said, you can be kind and true and fair and generous and just, and even merciful, occasionally. But to be that thing, time after time, you have to really have courage.
和民权活动家玛雅·安杰洛说，你可以偶尔善良、真实、公平、慷慨、公正，甚至仁慈。但要一次又一次地做到这一点，你必须真正拥有勇气。
Ranjay Gulladi is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He is the author of How to Be bold. the surprising science of everyday courage. Ranjay, in your studies of courageous people, you found that they deliberately cultivate a capacity known as self-efficacy. What is self-efficacy,
兰杰·古拉蒂是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。他是《如何变得大胆：日常勇气的惊人科学》一书的作者。兰杰，在你对勇敢者的研究中，你发现他们刻意培养了一种被称为自我效能感的能力。什么是自我效能感，
and how does it help people become braver? So self-efficacy, the construct, was first studied by a famous Stanford psychologist, Albert Bandura, who was trying to convince people who are fearful of snakes to hold a corn snake. and what is interesting is
它如何帮助人们变得更勇敢？“自我效能感”这一概念最早由斯坦福大学著名心理学家阿尔伯特·班杜拉提出，他当时试图说服那些害怕蛇的人去拿一条玉米锦蛇。有趣的是，
in that study and several others that he did he makes a very important distinction between the domain-specific efficacy that you may have and then a generalized efficacy that you may have. Domain-specific is, I am the master of my craft. I know my task, I'll do it, I'll get it done. Generalized efficacy is this general notion of I can do it. I got it.
在那项研究以及他所做的其他几项研究中，他做出了一个非常重要的区分：即你可能拥有的“领域特定效能感”和“广义效能感”。领域特定效能感是指：我是我这一行的专家。我了解我的任务，我会去做，并且能完成。广义效能感则是指一种普遍的信念：我能行。我搞得定。
bring it on captain sullenberger landing a plane on the hudson river you know sure he was a seasoned veteran 40 year pilot fighter pilot before that but he had never really trained simulated landing on a river but you know when he was interviewed by katie kurek who asked him like look you know what do you need to do he said oh yeah i knew the textbook this this this this this this he says but there was still a big if and he looked at it and he says i knew i could do it that I knew I could do it. That kind of confidence, if I may call it that, which is this generalized can-do spirit,
放马过来吧。萨伦伯格机长在哈德逊河上迫降飞机，当然，他是一位经验丰富的老手，在此之前做了40年的飞行员和战斗机飞行员，但他从未真正模拟过在河上降落。但你知道，当凯蒂·库里克采访他，问他当时需要做什么时，他说：“哦，是的，我知道教科书上写的那些步骤。”但他表示，当时仍然存在巨大的不确定性，他看着这一切，心想：“我知道我能做到，我知道我能做到。”那种自信，如果可以这样称呼的话，就是一种广义的“我能行”的精神，
that becomes the kernel of what allows us to then ultimately take bold action even in the face of uncertainty. I mean, in some ways, we heard this in the story you told about your mother. I mean, she had a domain-specific self-efficacy. She was a designer. She must have been very good at her craft. But clearly, she also had a higher-level sense of self-efficacy because she said, even when I'm confronting somebody who shows up at my house with a gun,
这成为了我们最终能够在面对不确定性时采取大胆行动的核心。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我们在你讲述的关于你母亲的故事中听到了这一点。她拥有领域特定的自我效能感。她是一名设计师，她在自己的专业领域一定非常出色。但显然，她也拥有更高层次的自我效能感，因为她说，即使面对一个拿着枪出现在我家门口的人，
I know that I'll be able to handle the situation. I think most entrepreneurs, I shouldn't say most, but many entrepreneurs have that general sensibility because, you know, things are changing so fast around them and the curve balls coming at them are so many from so many directions by necessity but you're right i think in if i look at her from afar you know her life was always one of the i got it nothing would kind of phase her how do we cultivate that that's the question now and what is the answer to that question because again i think people might say some people just have it some people don't but i think your theory is that
我也知道我能处理好这种情况。我认为大多数企业家——我不应该说大多数，但许多企业家都有这种普遍的感知力，因为他们周围的事物变化太快，他们不得不从四面八方应对各种突发状况。但你是对的，如果我从远处观察她，她的生活总是充满着“我能搞定”的态度，没有什么能让她动摇。现在的问题是，我们该如何培养这种能力？这个问题的答案是什么？因为同样，人们可能会说有些人天生就有，有些人没有，但我认为你的理论是，
in fact, this is something that can be grown, can be cultivated. Look, it starts with domain-specific efficacy, first of all. You have to be the master of your craft. You have to really understand your craft in a way that nobody else does. It should be deeply internalized into who you are. Then when you go beyond that, I find you can take yourself so far, but sometimes you need external validation. what do coaches do so well for teams you know what do they do they help the player believe in themselves
事实上，这是可以培养和增长的。首先，它始于领域特定的效能感。你必须成为你所在领域的专家。你必须以一种无人能及的方式真正理解你的专业。它应该深深地内化为你的一部分。然后，当你超越这一点时，我发现你虽然可以走得很远，但有时你需要外部的认可。教练在团队中做得很好，他们做了什么？他们帮助球员相信自己。
that self-belief i know you got it and and i think that becomes part of the story so you're looking for external sources of validation as well and then when you're playing for somebody else when you're doing it for something bigger than yourself that further boosts up your confidence that I got it, I can do it. This self-belief sometimes comes from within and sometimes comes from an externalized source who also believes in you. A very dramatic example of how domain-specific self-efficacy
那种自信——“我知道你能行”——我认为这成为了故事的一部分。所以你也在寻找外部的认可来源，当你为别人而战，当你为比自己更宏大的目标而努力时，这会进一步提升你的自信，让你觉得“我能行，我做得到”。这种自信有时来自内心，有时来自也相信你的外部来源。一个关于领域特定自我效能感如何
can lead to generalize self-efficacy is in the story of the terrorist attack on the Taj Mahal Palace Hotel in Mumbai, India in 2008. What happened that day, Ranja, and how did employees at the hotel respond? So several terrorists found their way into the hotel and laid a siege on the hotel for the next 60 hours. They were marauding around the hotel, they were lighting fires, they were shooting guests, they were shooting employees,
转化为广义自我效能感的戏剧性例子，是2008年印度孟买泰姬陵酒店恐怖袭击事件的故事。那天发生了什么，兰杰？酒店员工是如何应对的？几名恐怖分子潜入酒店，并在接下来的60小时内对酒店进行了围攻。他们在酒店里横冲直撞，放火、射杀客人和员工，
basically trying to wreak havoc as much as they could. and meanwhile there was no way for the police and commanders to even go in they didn't know what to do there was a bit of a mess over there and what is interesting is none of the employees ran away even the in fact the hotel operators whose cubicles were right behind the front desk evacuated soon after the attacks came back in because they realized all the guests stuck in their rooms were calling and trying to get help. And so they all went back into the hotel. But the story I think best exemplifies this is Malika Jaggat, 24 years old. She's been assigned an event to welcome the new CEO of Global Unilever, Paul Polman. And there is a farewell for the departing
基本上是在尽其所能制造混乱。与此同时，警察和指挥官根本无法进入，他们不知道该怎么办，现场一片混乱。有趣的是，没有一个员工逃跑。事实上，那些工位就在前台后面的酒店接线员在袭击发生后不久撤离了，但他们又回来了，因为他们意识到所有被困在房间里的客人都打来电话寻求帮助。于是他们都回到了酒店。但我认为最能体现这一点的故事是24岁的马利卡·贾加特。她被指派负责欢迎全球联合利华新任首席执行官保罗·波尔曼的活动。当时还有一场为即将离任的
CEO. And the global leadership of Unilever is there, including the Indian leadership as well. And she's in charge of this event. And now you have the siege in the hotel. And the siege in the hotel. She locks the doors, tells everybody things are not okay, makes them lie down on the floor and asks them to stay quiet. This goes on the whole night. Right? And she's in charge. As she explained later, she was the youngest in the room, actually.
首席执行官举办的欢送会。联合利华的全球领导层都在那里，包括印度区的领导层。她负责这次活动。现在酒店发生了围攻。她锁上门，告诉大家情况不妙，让他们躺在地板上并保持安静。这种情况持续了整整一夜。对吧？她是负责人。正如她后来解释的那样，她其实是房间里最年轻的人。
But she was in charge. And there's no script for this, right? She's now working way beyond script. All she knows, her script is take care of the guests. And the purpose statement in the Taj's guest is God. Adhisi Deva, which means guest is God. And that's all she can think of. And then early hours on the morning, there's a fire lit outside in the hallway.
但她是负责人。这没有剧本可循，对吧？她现在的工作完全超出了剧本。她所知道的、她的剧本就是照顾好客人。泰姬陵酒店的宗旨是“客即是神”（Atithi Devo Bhava），意思是客人就是神。这就是她唯一能想到的。然后在清晨，走廊外起火了。
So now smoke is coming into this conference in this big room. And they have to get out or they're going to die. So she instructs two of her staffers to try to break the windows, which are big, thick windows. They use chairs and manage to break one of the windows. They see the general manager down there They wave to him He sees them He sees the smoke coming out of the room
现在烟雾正进入这个会议室。他们必须离开，否则就会死。于是她指示两名员工尝试打破窗户，那些窗户又大又厚。他们用椅子设法打破了其中一扇窗户。他们看到了楼下的总经理，他们向他挥手。他看到了他们，也看到了从房间里冒出的烟雾。
He directs the firefighters there A ladder is put Malika makes everybody All the guests get out first She's the last one off Out of the room Now you ask yourself What training did she have
他指挥消防员赶到那里，架起梯子。马利卡让所有人——所有客人都先撤离。她是最后一个离开房间的人。现在你问自己，她受过什么训练？
You know To carry her through this moment And she said you know, in an interview afterwards, she said, I was just doing my job. So, Ranjay, we've been talking about very rational and deliberate approaches to cultivate courage. But you also write about a different path to becoming braver, and that is calling upon our faith.
来支撑她度过这一刻？她在事后的采访中说：“我只是在做我的工作。”所以，兰杰，我们一直在谈论培养勇气的非常理性且审慎的方法。但你也写到了通往勇敢的另一条路径，那就是呼唤我们的信仰。
What have you discovered about the link between courage and faith? So human beings for thousands of years have had to deal with uncertainty. You know, weather uncertainty, you know, geopolitical uncertainty. And for the longest time, we have believed in a higher power. A higher source. Something bigger than us is there to take care of me.
你发现了勇气与信仰之间有什么联系？几千年来，人类不得不应对不确定性。你知道，天气的不可预测性，地缘政治的不确定性。长期以来，我们一直相信有一种更高的力量。一个更高的源头。某种比我们更伟大的存在在那里照顾我。
Now, I don't want to debate right now. whether there is a force or not, we can have a long discussion about that. But at the venom, it definitely calms us down, knowing that there is a higher power of force there for me. In some ways, I would call it outwitting our fear
现在，我不想在这里争论是否存在这种力量，我们可以对此进行长时间的讨论。但无论如何，知道有一种更高的力量在支持我，这确实让我们平静下来。在某种程度上，我会称之为智胜我们的恐惧，
or taming our fear. Because knowing that I'm supported by this higher force gives me the comfort, the confidence, the belief that, you know what, it looks dangerous, it looks scary, but I know something bigger than me has my back. And people manifest this in many different ways.
或者驯服我们的恐惧。因为知道我得到了这种更高力量的支持，给了我安慰、自信和信念，让我觉得：你知道吗，这看起来很危险，看起来很可怕，但我知道有比我更强大的力量在支持我。人们以许多不同的方式体现这一点。
You write about a firefighter named Joe Ibarra and the way he used his faith to face a terrifying situation with great courage. Tell me his story. So here's a firefighter who is a firefighter who is, in Idaho fighting a forest fire. And on day one, the fire looks pretty okay, tame and so forth, and they're trying to kind of contain it and figure it out. And then the next day, the fire explodes. It gets so, so dangerous and so bad. His supervisor announces that they, this is out of control, we need to go into our fire tents. And so here he is, he has a radio, he has his
你写到了一位名叫乔·伊巴拉的消防员，以及他如何利用信仰以极大的勇气面对可怕的处境。讲讲他的故事吧。这是一位在爱达荷州扑灭森林大火的消防员。第一天，火势看起来还算可以，比较温和，他们试图控制住火势并弄清楚情况。然后第二天，火势爆发了。情况变得非常、非常危险和糟糕。他的主管宣布火势失控，我们需要进入避火帐篷。所以他当时手里拿着无线电，
fire tent, and he has a rosary. And he's holding on to this rosary because he's being believes that if he has the rosary, he'll be protected. And he's praying. And magically, just soon after, a helicopter comes and dumps a bunch of water on them and douses the fire. And in his mind, this was just another manifestation of this higher power that was there for him.
避火帐篷，还有一个念珠。他紧紧抓着这串念珠，因为他相信如果他有念珠，他就会受到保护。他在祈祷。奇迹般地，就在不久之后，一架直升机飞来，向他们倾倒了大量的水，扑灭了大火。在他看来，这只是那种守护他的更高力量的又一次显现。
In his mind, he believes firmly that with this rosary, he'll always be safe. So you told me at the start of our conversation, Ranji, that you yourself have always been a very cautious person, a very deliberate person, you think about the risks before you embark on something. Have you, after all of this study about the science of bravery, have you tried to take it upon yourself to become a braver person? You know, I think that moment with my mother probably haunted me more than I would like
在他心中，他坚定地相信只要有这串念珠，他就会永远安全。所以你在谈话开始时告诉我，兰杰，你自己一直是一个非常谨慎、非常审慎的人，你在着手做某事之前会考虑风险。在研究了勇气的科学之后，你是否尝试过让自己成为一个更勇敢的人？你知道，我想我母亲的那一刻可能比我愿意承认的更困扰我。
to admit. But I actually, after, soon after, I actually decided I was going to try and put myself in situations that made me a little uncomfortable. So, very early, when I came to the U.S., I went to flight school to learn how to fly a plane. I never told my parents about that. But off I went to fly. And, you know, it was okay, as long as I had an instructor next to me, you know, and you're okay flying.
但我确实在之后不久决定，我要尝试让自己处于一些让我感到有点不舒服的境地。所以，我很早以前刚到美国时，就去飞行学校学习如何驾驶飞机。我从未告诉过我的父母。但我还是去学飞行了。你知道，只要旁边有教练，一切都还好，你飞行时会很安心。
And, you know, it's, and he showed us that you can glide the plane if the engine shuts off. And so intellectually, you kind of got it. But the big moment for a personal training is when you go solo, your first solo flight. That was a long time ago. It was 1985. I still remember my solo flight because I had in my head decided that I was going to imagine that Jerry, my instructor, was sitting next to me. And the entire flight, I was in conversation with Jerry. You know, Jerry props are up, you know, taking off, you know, calling ground control.
而且，他向我们展示了如果引擎熄火，你可以滑翔飞机。所以从理智上讲，你理解了这一点。但个人训练的关键时刻是你进行单飞的时候，你的第一次单飞。那是很久以前的事了，是1985年。我仍然记得我的单飞，因为我在脑海里决定，我要想象杰瑞，我的教练，正坐在我旁边。整个飞行过程中，我都在和杰瑞交谈。你知道，“杰瑞，螺旋桨转速调高”，“起飞了”，“呼叫地面控制”。
I'm talking to Jerry and here I was talking my way through the flight. I needed to comfort myself. I came to realize, you know, that fear is natural. You know, I had gotten over the shame of fear. That was very important. That for me, the first step was the shame I felt when I felt scared. I needed to overcome that part. Now I overcome the shame.
我在和杰瑞说话，我就这样一路谈着完成了飞行。我需要安慰自己。我开始意识到，恐惧是自然的。我已经克服了对恐惧的羞耻感。这非常重要。对我来说，第一步是我在感到害怕时所感受到的羞耻感。我需要克服那一部分。现在我克服了羞耻感。
Now I had to figure out how to tame my fear. And I'm trying to find a way to tame my fear. And then I have to take it to the next level. I'm going to act in spite of my fear. You can never eliminate fear. I can't tame it to zero. So I had to cross that chasm from shame to tame to really transcend. And that was my first for real.
现在我必须弄清楚如何驯服我的恐惧。我正在努力寻找驯服恐惧的方法。然后我必须把它提升到一个新的水平。我要在恐惧中采取行动。你永远无法消除恐惧。我无法将其驯服到零。所以我必须跨越从“羞耻”到“驯服”再到“超越”的鸿沟。那是我的第一次真正尝试。
I did another thing as well. I also then realized that I was not too comfortable in deep water. I think watching the movie Jaws really did me in. So I learned how to windsurf. And off I went to learn how to windsurf. And I spent several summers windsurfing. And again, not the most comfortable thing for me when I first started it. But I was determined to show myself.
我还做了另一件事。我还意识到我对深水不太适应。我想看电影《大白鲨》真的把我吓坏了。所以我学会了帆板运动。于是我去学习帆板。我花了好几个夏天练习帆板。同样，刚开始时这对我来说并不是最舒服的事情。但我决心向自己证明。
It wasn't to show my mother. My mother didn't even know all most of these things were happening. But I was determined to show myself that I could do it. As you have listened to this episode, you might be thinking of people in your life who could use a dose of bravery. Do you have a fearful child or a fearful parent? a colleague who always worries about worst-case scenarios? Would you like to help them discover their inner lion? In our companion story to this episode,
这不是为了向我母亲证明。我母亲甚至不知道这些事情中的大部分正在发生。但我决心向自己证明我能做到。当你听完这一集时，你可能会想到你生命中那些需要一点勇气的人。你有一个胆小的孩子或胆小的父母吗？一个总是担心最坏情况的同事吗？你想帮助他们发现内心的狮子吗？在我们这一集的配套故事中，
available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore how we can help others become more courageous. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled How to Help Others Be Brave. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org or Apple.com slash hidden brain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain.
仅供Hidden Brain Plus订阅者使用，我们探讨了如何帮助他人变得更加勇敢。如果你是订阅者，那一集现在就可以收听。标题是《如何帮助他人变得勇敢》。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 Apple.com/hiddenbrain。你将立即获得我们所有仅限订阅者的内容，包括过往剧集。再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。
Ranjay Kulari is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He's the author of How to Be Bold, the surprising science of everyday courage. Ranjay, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's been a pleasure to be with you today. If you have a question or a personal story about courage that you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us.
兰杰·古拉蒂是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。他是《如何大胆：日常勇气的惊人科学》一书的作者。兰杰，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢你，尚卡尔。今天能和你在一起真是太高兴了。如果你有一个关于勇气的问题或个人故事愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享，请找一个非常安静的房间录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。然后把文件通过电子邮件发给我们。
at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, frightened. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写“frightened”。再说一遍，是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our U2.0 series, how to get going again when you're stuck in a rut. In any pursuit, it doesn't really matter what you're doing, but trying multiple approaches, experimenting, figuring out whether the dominant approach is the right one or whether you should try something a bit different is the way forward. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.
我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。下周在我们的U2.0系列中，我们将探讨当你陷入困境时如何重新出发。在任何追求中，你正在做什么并不重要，但尝试多种方法、进行实验、弄清楚主导方法是否正确，或者你是否应该尝试一些不同的东西，才是前进的方向。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。
Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。